hier kann es nämlich gleich weitergehen
mit dem nächsten Punkt und das ist auch
ein ganz interessanter Punkt Änderung
des
energie-sicherheitsgesetzes zweite und
dritte Beratung des von den Fraktionen
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Entwurfs einen zweiten
Gesetzes zur Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes und anderer
energiewirtschaftlicher Vorschriften die
Novelle des Gesetzes das in seiner
aktuellen Fassung seit der Ölkrise 1975
bestehen die dazu die Krisenvorsorge zu
stärken und im Ernstfall schnell
handlungsfähig zu sein unter anderem
wird darin gefordert den Biogas Deckel
wegzunehmen die das repowering-verbot
also die Modernisierung für Solarparks
das ab 2023 fällig war wegzunehmen so
dass Solarparks künftig ihre Leistung
steigern können und einige andere Punkte
aber darum geht es hier in diesem Antrag
der jetzt hier als nächstes
auf dem Plan
und es gibt noch einen schließ
Entschließungsantrag der cdu/cs oder zu
der kommen wir aber später zu
es ich mich bitte jetzt noch einmal
Platz zu nehmen
ja und die die hier sitzen sind für das
Thema eingeteilt müssen aber nicht
vergessen noch abzustimmen zwischendurch
wird der ein oder andere Mal aufstehen
und rausgehen weit ist es ja nicht also
die erste Rednerin hier sind die neuen
debattenpunkt
der nennt sich Moment Änderung der
energiesicherheitsgesetzes Julia
Verlinden stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ich möchte vier
Punkte machen zum einen möchte ich daran
erinnern dass wir einen riesigen Booster
ein Energiepaket im Sommer verabschiedet
haben hier gemeinsam im Juli und damit
die Weichen gestellt haben für einen
massiven schnelleren Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und dass das
dringend notwendig ist das sehen wir
auch wieder in den Debatten der letzten
Wochen und Monate wie wichtig das ist
dass wir uns unabhängig machen von den
fossilen Rohstoffimporten und wie
wertvoll es ist dass wir eben diese
günstige Energieform hier massiv
ausbauen
und jetzt sind die Kommunen dran sind
die Länder dran
insbesondere in Bayern merken wir wie
die Debatte hochkocht darüber wo ist
denn oder ist denn genug Strom da wird
denn genug Strom auch durch die
Leitungen transportiert und so weiter
und so fort und ich glaube viele fangen
an nachzudenken ob das was in den
letzten Jahren für eine Position
vertreten haben wirklich die richtige
war und jetzt geht es darum zusätzlich
die bereits bestehenden Erneuerbaren
energienanlagen zu nutzen um diese
günstige Energieform noch weiter da
quasi aus den bestehenden Anlagen
rauszuholen denn es gab in der
Vergangenheit politische
Fehlentscheidungen die Deckel eingezogen
haben die gesagt haben okay du darfst
zwar eine Solaranlage auf dein Dach
setzen aber sie darf nicht 100% Leistung
ins Netz einspeisen und das war wirklich
eine Absurdität und da räumen wir jetzt
vernünftig auf
der zweite der dritte Punkt den ich
machen möchte ist dass wir
selbstverständlich noch viel viel mehr
auch tun werden und bereits dabei sind
auch in den Bereich Energie sparen
Energieeffizienz zu investieren vieles
können natürlich die Menschen jetzt
bereits selber tun und wir haben wieder
den
aktiven Aufruf auch von der
Bundesnetzagentur in den letzten Tagen
gehört wie wichtig das ist das
Unternehmen die das bereits tun
fortsetzen aber auch Privatpersonen
endlich noch viel mehr Energie sparen
damit wir gut über diesen Winter kommen
die Gasspeicher sind dankenswerterweise
voll durch das Gute Management unserer
Regierung auch und durch der durch die
Bundesnetzagentur aber es muss eben noch
mehr getan werden auch beim
Energiesparen das nützt auch allen in
Ihrem Geldbeutel
und was wir nicht vergessen dürfen ist
es müssen auch Investitionen fließen in
moderne Heizungen in neue Technik und da
haben wir glücklicherweise auch gute
Förderprogramme auf die zurückgegriffen
werden kann
und den vierten und letzten Punkt den
ich machen möchte angesichts des
energiesicherungsgesetzes ist dass ich
danke sagen möchte danke auch an die
Oppositionsfraktion der Linken und der
Union weil sie auch mit dazu beigetragen
haben dass wir hier ein sehr zügiges
Verfahren gehabt haben im Bundestag wir
haben zu sehr unkonventionellen Zeiten
eine Sachverständigen Anhörung um 7 Uhr
morgens im Ausschuss gehabt es ist eine
Herausforderung im Augenblick auch für
dieses Parlament für die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Ausschüssen in den Abgeordnetenbüros in
den Fraktionen auch für die
Sachverständigen ist das keine normale
Uhrzeit und ich glaube dass wir damit
zeigen als Parlament dass wir in dieser
Krise handlungsfähig sind vielen Dank
auf Julia Verlinden antwortet jetzt
Alexander Dobrindt der landesgruppenchef
der CSU
landesgruppenchef der CSU der CSU
Stellvertreter der cdu/csu als
Fraktionschef und wenn die CSU nicht in
einer Fraktionsgemeinschaft wäre wäre
Alexander Dober und der
Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Energiemangel bedroht unsere
Wirtschaft explodierende Energiepreise
bedrohen den sozialen Frieden wir teilen
die Einschätzung des
Bundesfinanzministers dass wir eine
energiekrieg erleben wir teilen übrigens
auch die Einschätzung des Bundeskanzlers
das ist eine große Kraftanstrengung
braucht aber nicht erst seit gestern
meine Damen und Herren wir unterstützen
notwendige Maßnahmen wenn sie vertrauen
Sicherheit und wirtschaftliche
Stabilität bieten aber es reicht
schlichtweg nicht alleine aus
Energiepolitik durch Finanzpolitik
ersetzen zu wollen meine Damen und
Herren
es ist notwendig zu entscheiden mit wie
viel Geld der Staat ist bereit in die
Krise einzuspringen aber es ist doch
noch wichtiger zu erfahren bei wem
dieses Geld ankommt das haben sie
gestern leider versäumt Haushalte
Mittelstand Wirtschaft sie wissen nicht
was ankommt sie haben keinen doppelten
Wunsch verspürt sondern ein doppeltes
Fragezeichen aufgestellt
sie machen eine Politik der großen
Zahlen 200 Milliarden zugegebenermaßen
das ist erstmal
beeindruckend sie können leider nicht
erläutern wie diese Zahl sich
zusammensetzt das schafft neue
Unsicherheiten wir unterstützen Sie
dabei eine gaspreisbremse einzuführen
wir haben sie vor Monaten schon dazu
aufgefordert dieses Instrument zu nutzen
sie haben es lange Zeit nicht für
notwendig erachtet sie wollen jetzt
einen bürgerbasispreis einführen wir
haben Ihnen das vorgeschlagen aber sie
sagen nicht welche Preissenkung bei den
Haushalten ankommen sollen jeden Tag
bekommen die Haushalte aktuell
Vorauszahlungsbescheide die Gaskunden
kriegen Bescheide geschickt wo
preissteiger von drei vier fünf dem drei
vier fünffachen der bisherigen Zahlungen
draufstehen diese Menschen brauchen doch
endlich Klarheit was auf sie zukommt und
jetzt verweisen Sie auf eine Kommission
die Ende nächsten Monats irgendwelche
Ergebnisse präsentieren sollen sie
Zäunen das Pferd von hinten auf sagen
sie den Menschen wie sie entlasten
wollen dann wissen wir es was kostet und
nicht umgekehrt meine Damen und Herren
aber vielleicht fällt Ihnen ja die
Reihenfolge deswegen so schwer weil sie
seit Monaten einen toten Gaul geritten
haben sie feiern sicher hier den ganzen
Vormittag schon für den Stopp der
gasumlage Verzeihung meine Damen und
Herren aber Herr Habeck ist nicht der
Erlöser sondern der Erschaffer der
gasumlage das doch die Wahrheit
sie haben die gasumlage an die Wand
gefahren als wir sie aufgefordert haben
übrigens hier im Deutschen Bundestag
mehrmals diese gasumlage zu stoppen da
hat der Bundesminister Harbig uns in der
letzten Woche noch im Deutschen
Bundestag als Opposition beschimpft der
hat uns als die muss weg
Opposition bezeichnet heute schaffen Sie
die gasumlage ab offensichtlich sind sie
die muss weg Koalition und da sollte der
muss weg Minister sitzen meine Damen und
Herren
Kollege Dobrindt
ich habe die Uhr angehalten gestatten
Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hallo Prinz wir teilen das Schicksal in
Bundesländern zu leben wo es mit dem
Windkraftausbau überhaupt nicht
vorangeht
wir haben
dann kann ich ihn nicht ersparen die
Ergänzung wir haben es in Chemnitz
geschafft mit Unterstützung von VW
Sachsen ein Beschluss zu fassen der
trotz schwierigster
Mehrheitsverhältnisse für mehr
Windenergie selbst in der Stadt spricht
wenn Sie das albern sehen tut mir das
wirklich leid das ist
industrieschädigend was sie hier tun
Herr Dobrindt eine konkrete Frage wann
gehen wir in ihrem Wahlkreis das letzte
Windrad ans Netz dankeschön
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Kollege herzlichen Dank für
Ihre Frage ich will auf eine Antwort der
Bundesregierung verweisen auf eine
aktuelle Antwort der Bundesregierung aus
diesem Monat in dieser Antwort teilt das
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz mit an der Spitze der
erneuerbaren Energien aller Bundesländer
steht das Bundesland Freistaat Bayern
erste Feststellung
zweite Feststellung aus dem
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz bei den einzelnen
Technologien Biomasse steht an erster
Stelle Bayern Solarenergie steht an
erster Stelle Bayern Geothermie steht an
erster Stelle Bayern Wasserkraft steht
an erster Stelle Bayern bei der
Windkraft steht Bayern vor
Baden-Württemberg deutlich beim neuen
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien dieses
Jahr vorne Bayern das einzige wo Bayern
wirklich nicht gut ist das ist der
Windkraft auf der See meine Damen und
Herren sonst überall
[Applaus]
übrigens die Antwort des
Bundesministeriums gerne auch noch
schriftlich mit
der Bundesfinanzminister hat gestern in
der
Pressekonferenz zutreffend erklärt je
besser die Senkung der Energiepreise im
Markt stattfindet desto weniger würde
aus den 200 Milliarden Euro benötigt
werden ich stimme ihm da ausdrücklich zu
aber dazu muss man auch bereit sein dass
Angebot zu erhöhen die Kapazität bei der
Energieerzeugung auszuweiten um die
Preise zu senken um in der Sprache des
Finanzministers zu bleiben All-In bei
allen
energieerzeuern aber was sagt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister dazu diese
Woche wir haben nicht zu wenig Strom wir
haben nur keine Netzstabilität ja
vielleicht kann man diese Kontinuität im
Irrtum endlich mal beenden meine Damen
und Herren
so und die grüne weiß ich so laut
schreien von den Grünen hier die grüne
Spitzenkandidatin in Niedersachsen hat
diese Woche erklärt
Atomstrom blockiert das Netz ja meine
Damen und Herren falls es noch nicht für
alle klar geworden ist wir haben nicht
so viel Strom im Netz sondern wir haben
zu wenig und das einzige was im Moment
das Netz blockiert das ist die
ideologische Verweigerungshaltung der
Grünen die Kernkraft um zwei Jahre zu
verlängern daran scheitert es in diesem
Land
so sehr viel Applaus der Unionsfraktion
jetzt für Alexander Dobrindt aufmerksam
dass die Zeit für die namentliche
Abstimmung in fünf Minuten zu Ende geht
sollte es noch Kollegen und Kollegen
geben die nicht die Gelegenheit hatten
die Stimme abzugeben dann sollten Sie es
tun ich habe den Einwand gehört als
nächstes hat die Kollegen Dr Nina Scheer
für die SPD-Fraktion das Wort ist die
Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und Energie
und die Tochter von Hermann dem
ehemaligen Alternativen Nobelpreisträger
der ja schon verstorben ist
ich finde es schon erschreckend wie aus
den Reihen von cdu/csu mit tosendem
Beifall überdeckt werden soll das in
Land Bayern und auch unter der
leitlinienpolitik von cdu/csu eine
rückwärtsgewandte Energiepolitik gemacht
wurde eine rückwärtsgewandte
Energiepolitik und wir als SPD-Fraktion
wirklich alle Mühe hatten wenigstens
kleine Schritte zu erkämpfen in der
Frage die Fehlstellung wieder rückgängig
zu machen und da hilft es auch nicht
wenn sie auf kleine Fehlstellungen in
einzelnen Bundesländern jetzt Reiskörner
suchend um die um die in der in ihrer
Rede Vorgehen sie überdecken damit und
Täuschen damit darüber hinweg dass in
Bayern systematisch aber wirklich
systematisch die Energiewende
ausgebremst wird schon seit Jahren
die Frage der gasumlage ist ebenfalls
ein Tagesordnungspunkt tatsächlich kurz
darauf eingehen wir haben jetzt eine
Einigung die ist jetzt auch zügig
erfolgt nach einem langen Ringen um die
große Aufgabe die damit in Rede steht
wenn Gas und auch Energie insgesamt
aufgrund der fossilen energiepreiskrise
über die letzten Monate verschärft zum
Problem geworden ist und da ist es auch
kein Spaziergang so etwas so zu
organisieren dass es rechtssicher
Bestand hat insofern danke ich auch in
Richtung Bundesregierung das nun ein Weg
gefunden wurde der uns diesen
rechtssicheren Weg eröffnet es ist ein
stabiles Volumen was wir jetzt an die
Hand bekommen damit tatsächlich
Energiesicherheit auch preislich
gewährleistet werden kann in diesem
Sinne haben wir einen gemeinsamen Weg
jetzt nun gefunden und da danke ich und
bin auch frohen mutig dass wir jetzt
eine Wende in der Situation hinbekommen
dass Energie auch verlässlich wieder
verfügbar und bezahlbar über die
nächsten Monate sein wird zumindest in
dem Rahmen in dem das zu sicherungsfähig
ist es ist natürlich zu betonen dass wir
alle gehalten sind weiterhin so viel wie
eine irgendwie geht einzusparen der
zweite top der zweite Tagesordnungspunkt
der beim dieser Plenardebatte heute aber
mit dem Top zusammengefasst ist ist das
wie wesentlichere nämlich unsere Option
unsere Möglichkeit die wir uns hiermit
noch mal verstärkt geben mit den
Änderungen am energiesicherungsgesetz
ein mit dem erneuerbaren Energien
Booster mit einer verstärkten
auslastungsmöglichkeit für erneuerbare
Energien den Umstieg auf erneuerbare
Energien die wird dringend brauchen um
der fossilen energiepreiskrise zu
entkommen um diesen Ausbau um diesen
Umstieg auf erneuerbare und die
Auslastung der Erneuerbaren noch
verstärkt hinzubekommen
hier muss es jetzt verstärkt geben weil
natürlich alle Energie die wir noch mehr
gewinnen können über die nächsten Monate
auch schon mit bestehenden Anlagen
Goldwert sind und dazu gehört etwas dass
wir vereinfacht das Repowering machen
das bei Veränderungen der Anlagen nicht
extra Genehmigungen eingeholt werden
müssen dazu gehört dass man
nachtabsenkungen für windenergietemporär
aussetzt weil dadurch einfach enorme
Potenziale verloren geht dazu gehört
auch dass wir sonder in den
Ausschreibungen die für Photovoltaik
vorgenommen werden dass wir da die Höhen
die Mengen erhöhen damit einfach noch
mehr ausgeschrieben werden kann und dazu
gehört auch und da möchte ich noch mal
ein ganz dickes Dankeschön auch an
unsere bauministerin Clara Gallwitz
aussprechen die einen Teil ihrer Novelle
aus dem Herbst jetzt vorgezogen uns zur
Verfügung gestellt hat dass wir jetzt
auch bei der Bioenergie enorme
Potenziale mit bestehenden Anlagen Herr
noch auskosten können durch mehr Stoffe
die da eingesetzt werden können also die
die Mengen werden erhöht die Mengen der
einsetzbaren Stoffe werden erhöht die
Norm Kubikmeter Grenze wird temporär
ausgesetzt und zwar bis in
einschließlich 24 und das ist ein
enormes Potenzial was wir dadurch noch
mal ergänzt bekommen herzlichen Dank an
Klara geibels an dieser Stelle nochmal
und in diesem Sinne wir sind auf einem
guten Weg mit einem kräftigen Energie
Booster mit dieser Energie-
ich mache darauf aufmerksam dass ich
nach dem nächsten Redebeitrag die
namentliche Abstimmung schließe Kollegin
Scheer sie können das ganz in Ruhe
machen nicht dass es da noch und Frage
aber auch noch einmal ist sind noch
weitere Mitglieder des Hauses anwesend
die noch nicht die Gelegenheit hatten
ihre Stimme in der namentlichen
Abstimmung abzugeben dann haben sie
namentliche Abstimmung läuft jetzt noch
vier Minuten so lange hat nämlich Mark
Bernhard von der AFD als nächster Redner
das Wort und es geht in dieser
Abstimmung um einen Antrag der cdu/csu
der hier vorhin beraten wurde für
skalpolitische Disziplin in Europa von
der Union namentlich gewünscht in vier
Minuten ist Schluss mag Bernhard
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
als die Reisegruppe merkte dass sie sich
verlaufen hatte erhöhte sie das Tempo
genauso kommt mir der Aktionismus der
Bundesregierung vor wenn man merkt dass
man auf dem falschen Weg ist nützt es
nichts die Geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen
man kann Industrieland eben nicht mit
Sonne und Wind allein betreiben
das hat jeder in diesem Land verstanden
nur ganz offensichtlich die
Bundesregierung nicht
obwohl angeblich jede Kilowattstunde
zählt geht es in dem heute vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf einzig und allein darum
instabile Energien weiter auszubauen und
in keinster Weise darum die Menschen
unbeschadet über diesen und den nächsten
Winter zu bringen sondern einzig und
allein darum Deutschland mit
solar-industrieanlagen zuzupflastern
wo aber die Energie herkommt wenn es
nach diesem kein Wind weht und vor allem
wie die Menschen die Energiekosten
bezahlen sollen darauf gibt es von ihnen
keine Antwort seit Beginn des Jahres
haben sich die Gaspreise mindestens
verdreifacht die Strompreise verdoppelt
die Lebensmittelpreise extrem erhöht und
wir haben eine Inflationsrate von über
zehn Prozent das Geld der Bürger wird
immer weniger wert und diese Regierung
verdient sich durch diese Preisexplosion
und die dadurch immer weiter steigenden
Mehrwertsteuereinnahmen am Leid der
Menschen dumm und dusselig
und jetzt und jetzt wollen sie uns doch
tatsächlich vorgaukeln sie würden die
Menschen mit ihrer Mehrwertsteuersenkung
für Gas von 19 auf 7% entlasten
wenn Sie bisher für Gas
119 Euro im Monat bezahlt haben also 100
Euro fürs Gas plus 19 Euro für die
Mehrwertsteuer dann müssten sie
theoretisch nach der Steuersenkung auf
7% nur noch 107 Euro bezahlen
das ist der Gaspreis aber verdreifacht
hat müssen die Menschen zukünftig für
die gleiche Menge Gas
300 Euro plus 21 Euro Mehrwertsteuer
trotzdem geringeren Steuersatz bezahlen
wo ist hier also bitte die Entlastung
und für und für die Sicherung der
Millionen gefährdeten Arbeitsplätze
bringt diese Regelung ja sowieso
überhaupt gar nichts so dass die
Abwanderung von Arbeitsplätzen ins
Ausland
unbebremst weitergeht
das bisherige energiesicherungsgesetz
hat den Menschen keinen offensichtlich
keine Sicherheit gebracht und die hier
debattierte Novelle geht in die gleiche
Richtung und verstärkt damit alle Fehler
das ist so als ob man einem Ertrinkenden
einen defekten Rettungsring zugeworfen
hat und ihm jetzt zur finalen Rettung
den nächsten defektenring hinterher
wirft wenn es ihnen tatsächlich darum
geht die Versorgung der Menschen mit
bezahlbarer Energie sicherzustellen
warum nutzen Sie da nicht unsere eigenen
Gasvorkommen die russische für viele
Jahrzehnte vollständig ersetzen können
warum geben sie den saubersten
Kohlekraftwerken der Welt keine Laufzeit
Garantie warum schalten Sie unsere Kürze
drei kürzlich abgestellten
Kernkraftwerke nicht wieder ein sondern
hoffen auf Stromlieferungen aus
ukrainischen und französischen
Atomkraftwerken und vor allem warum
lassen Sie dann nur zwei der drei
sichersten Kernkraftwerke der Welt
weiterlaufen können Sie es nicht oder
wollen Sie es einfach nicht
die Zeit für die namentliche Abstimmung
ist nun vorbei gleichwohl stelle ich
noch einmal die Frage ist noch ein
Mitglied des Hauses anwesend welches
seine Stimme nicht abgegeben hat
das ist nicht der Fall ich schließe die
Abstimmung und bitte die Schriftführerin
und Schriftführer mit der Auszählung zu
beginnen das Ergebnis der Abstimmung
wird Ihnen später bekannt gegeben
wir fahren in der Debatte fort das Wort
hat der Kollege Michael Kruse für die
FDP-Fraktion Michael Kruse ist der
energiepolitische Sprecher der FDP
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
haben in dieser Woche sehr viel über
Energiepolitik gesprochen in diesem Haus
kein Wunder ist ein wichtiges Thema wir
haben in den Reden sehr wenig Zeit
darauf verwendet die Frage zu besprechen
die mir die meisten Menschen in
persönlichen Gesprächen stellen nämlich
was tut ihr denn jetzt eigentlich ich
habe viele Reden aus der Opposition
gehört dazu wer die Verantwortung trägt
ehrlicherweise auch aus den
Regierungsfraktionen wahlweise sind es
die Kanzlerin und die letzten 16 Jahre
Politik oder aber eben die aktuelle
Regierung
ich habe das Gefühl darauf wird 90
Prozent der Zeit hier im Haus im Moment
verwendet
in den Gesprächen die ich persönlich
außerhalb dieses Hauses führe wird
darauf ungefähr zehn Prozent der Zeit
verwendet die anderen 90% widmen sich
der Fragestellung wie kommen wir jetzt
daraus und ich meine dass diese
Fragestellung eigentlich die relevantere
für uns alle hier ist denn die Menschen
haben uns ja mit einem Grund in dieses
Parlament gewählt damit wir Ihre
Probleme lösen und deswegen meine ich
dass wir auch in dieser Debatte das in
den Mittelpunkt stellen sollten viele
Menschen sagen tut doch jetzt alles was
notwendig ist und das ist genau der
Grund warum wir in diesem Jahr zum
dritten Mal an das
energiesicherungsgesetz von 1975
herangehen wir heben jetzt den Biomasse
Deckel und ich bin der Union dankbar
dass sie an diesem Punkt ja auch darauf
hingewiesen hat wie notwendig das ist
aber hier leider noch keine Worte dazu
gefunden hat dass wir es ja jetzt auch
tun und das ist eine sehr wichtige
Maßnahme ist wir geben eine Garantie
dafür dass die Kohlekraftwerke bis 2024
ans Netz zurückkehren weil wir wissen
dass wir das brauchen obwohl niemand in
diesem Haus nicht mal die Opposition
dafür
Wahlkampf gemacht hat im letzten Jahr
wir sorgen dafür dass in kritischen
Phasen einer gasmangellage auch mehr
Windenergie zur Verfügung steht weil wir
sicher sind dass die Abwägung vieler
Menschen in diesem Land lautet
bevor wir in einem mangelage geraten
sind wir bereit auch weitere
Einschränkungen zu akzeptieren und ja
auch der dem Thema Verlängerung der
Kernenergie widmet sich diese Koalition
und ich glaube schon das ist Ausdruck
großen Verantwortungsbewusstsein weil
alle sich völlig im Klaren sind welche
hohen Hürden es gibt welche hohen
Sicherheitsauflagen hier auch zu
erzielen sind und das ist aber trotzdem
dieses Land vor einer Situation steht
dass genau eine solche Verlängerung in
den nächsten Wintern notwendig sein
könnte und wir bereiten mit allen diesen
Maßnahmen das Land darauf vor dass es
gut durch die nächsten Winter kommt und
wenn ich eine Bitte äußern dürfte dann
würde ich ehrlicherweise insbesondere
Sie Herr Kollege Dobrindt ansprechen
wollen dieses Land braucht in dieser
Situation keine Büttenreden sondern es
braucht eine verantwortungsvoll handeln
die Regierung die jetzt die richtigen
Maßnahmen ergreift damit wir gut durch
den nächsten Winter kommen
und das sind ja nur ja was sage ich zur
Kernenergie her Dobrind das kann ich
Ihnen genau sagen was ich sage wenn all
das was Sie hier ebenso ulkig
dargestellt haben wenn all das so
dermaßen zutreffen würde dann müssten
sie mir eigentlich sagen nee die
Kernkraftwerke die können ja vom letzten
Mal in Bayern da haben wir ja so viel
erneuerbaren Strom dass wir gar kein
Problem haben aber Herr Dobrind wir
stimmen ja darin überein sie können
nicht vom Netz sie können nicht vom Netz
weil sie im Süden nicht genug ausgebaut
haben und da müssen sich dann irgendwann
auch in der Kritik entscheiden entweder
Sie haben so viel ausgebaut entweder Sie
haben es alles so toll im Griff oder
aber die Kernkraftwerke müssen länger
laufen beides geht nicht und zu einer
verantwortungsvollen Oppositionsarbeit
gehört dann auch dazu sich in der Kritik
zu entscheiden und nicht wahlweise das
vorzutragen was einem gerade am besten
passt
aber wir ergreifen ja nicht nur wichtige
Maßnahmen im Bereich der Energiepolitik
sondern wir sorgen auch dafür dass wir
die Menschen in diesem Land entlasten
denn auch hier ist ja die Fragestellung
was tut ihr denn dafür dass wir uns das
noch leisten können und in dieser
Situation haben wir erstmalig übrigens
etwas was sie sich auch immer gewünscht
haben die kalte Progression voll
ausgeglichen ich erwarte Beifall an
dieser Stelle sagen Sie es doch liebe
Ampel toll dass sie das hingekriegt
haben wir hätten es Ihnen nie zugetraut
aber sie haben es ja gemacht und dafür
sorgen wir sorgen ja nicht nur dafür
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
selbstverständlich
sehr geehrte Kollege Kruse danke dass
Sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen glauben
Sie nicht dass neben dem Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren auch grundlass gebraucht
wird und deckt sich das nicht mit
parteitagsbeschlüssen mit
parteibeschlüssen der FDP
die letzte Frage habe ich nicht
verstanden können deckt sich das nicht
mit parteibeschlüssen der FDP dass man
die Atomkraftwerke unabhängig vom Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren braucht also ich denke
nicht dass wir hier jetzt die
Beschlusslagen auf einzelne Parteien
miteinander diskutieren soll sie haben
ja sie haben ja den Anfang meiner Rede
gehört indem ich ja darauf hingewiesen
habe dass sich die Menschen jetzt gerade
eben nicht die Frage stellen wer wann
was beschlossen hat wer wann welchen
Teil an Verantwortung und Schuld trägt
sondern dass die Menschen sich vor allem
die Frage stellt wie kommen wir denn
jetzt aus diesem Schlamassel in dem wir
stecken wieder raus kann ihn natürlich
zu unserer Beschlusslage sagen dass wir
im Mai dieses Jahres oder im Ende April
dieses Jahres einen Parteitag hatten
indem wir schon darauf hingewiesen haben
dass es sein könnte dass wir diese
Kernkraftwerke als weitere Option haben
und das haben wir nicht getan weil wir
der Meinung sind dass wir das jetzt auf
alle Zeit als Technologie
weiterverfolgen wollen sondern das haben
wir getan weil es eine Konsequenz des
russischen angriffskriegs ist dass wir
jetzt alle Optionen prüfen müssen und
nichts ausschließen dürfen insofern ja
das ist unsere Beschlusslage aber
nochmal hier geht es nicht um
parteipolitische beschlusslang hier geht
es darum dass sich jede selbst die Frage
stellt was kann ich jetzt dazu beitragen
und wenn ihre Kollegen aus Bayern hier
dann ich sag mal Büttenreden halten dann
muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen sie
sollten sich auch die Frage stellen was
können Sie dazu beitragen dass wir aus
dieser Situation herauskommen und
vielleicht nicht den ganzen Teil ihrer
reden und jetzt auch ihrer
Zwischenfragen darauf verwenden welche
Partei hat denn ihm zu welchem Zeitpunkt
was beschlossen das stellen sich die
Menschen nicht als Frage und sie stellen
sich auch nicht die Frage ob sie
diejenigen sind die dann jetzt hier mit
solchen reden vielleicht ein paar
Punkten auf Kosten der Reha Regierung
machen können das ist am Ende dieser
Woche einfach nicht angemessen das
möchte ich Ihnen wirklich sagen weil wir
jetzt das dritte mal an ein Gesetz
rangehen was wir eigentlich gar nicht
zur Anwendung bringen möchten was seit
den 70er Jahren überhaupt nicht
angefasst worden ist und wir tun das
weil wir in großer Verantwortung für
dieses Land handeln und ich vermisse
ehrlich gesagt ihre Beiträge wo sie denn
auch diese Verantwortung zeigen weil sie
ja als Opposition eigentlich Regierung
im Wartestand sein müssten und dafür
eigentlich kämpfen müssten wieder in die
Regierung zu kommen und das kann ich an
ihren Redebeiträgen in diesem Haus in
dieser Woche zu diesem Thema leider gar
nicht erkennen
so aber neben der kalten Progression auf
die ich ja jetzt eben eingegangen bin
haben wir noch eine ganze Menge mehr
gemacht gerade haben wir die Senkung der
Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas beschlossen in
diesem Monat in diesen Tagen auch heute
am Ende dieses Monats kommt die
energiekostenpauschale bei den Menschen
an und wir haben die EEG-Umlage
abgeschafft schon zum ersten siebten
dieses Jahres um die Menschen zu
entlasten und wenn es weitere Probleme
gibt dann werden wir mit der
stromkostenbremse und der
gaskostenbremse weitere Entlastungen
herbeiführen herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
ich gebe Ihnen das von den
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführern
ermittelte Ergebnis der namentlichen
Abstimmung bekannt
abgegebene stimmenkarten
613 mit ja haben
169 Abgeordnete gestimmt mit Nein
stimmten
378 und es gab 66 Enthaltungen der
Antrag ist abgelehnt
so das war jetzt noch einmal der Antrag
der Unionsfraktion zur Stabilitätsunion
statt Schulden Union stabilitäts- und
wachstumstag packt festigen es wurde
aber abgelehnt Klaus Ernst spricht jetzt
für die Linke meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren ich habe ja wirklich einen
kleinen Reflex
zu verteidigen weil mir so eine rede
lieber als manche reden hier wo einem
die Füße einschlafen vor Langeweile und
wenn es die Faktenlage werden jetzt die
Faktenlage noch stimmt und da bitte ich
schon mal da müssen wir alle nachgucken
ob die Faktenlage so stimmt da muss die
ein oder andere Geschichte muss man dann
wirklich überdenken weil ich habe mir
gedacht die Bayern sind noch ich habe
schon geschämt dass ich einer bin aber
wenn das so ist dann ist natürlich die
Lage dann ist die Lage an es geht um
Fakten mit unserer zwischen brüllen und
ist dazwischen klären das dazwischen
plärren das dazwischen lernen das ist ja
auch eine bayerische Sache aber das ist
am Oktoberfest angebracht ohne den
Bundestag so also das wollte ich jetzt
hier mal einfach mal sagen also
anschauen anschauen auch für das gilt
auch für sie erstmal anschauen wenn sie
erfrischen Frage stellen wollen gerne
erst mal anschauen bevor man grün so
erste Punkt zweiter Punkt wir reden über
die
gasanpassungsverordnung die
gasanpassungsforten Beweis nicht warum
man dann nur darüber reden ist doch
toter wie ein toter die kommt doch
erledigt
aber wir müssen darüber reden warum weil
die Bundesregierung und die tragenden
Koalitionen nicht in der in der in der
Lage war die Fehler die mit dieser
gasumlage gemacht worden sind so
rechtzeitig zu korrigieren dass man
nicht jetzt ist er schon wieder da also
die Oktoberfest geht die Oktoberfest
geht noch diesen Montag also bitte sie
haben nur Scheiße also es ist nicht in
der Lage gewesen diese gasumlage
ordnungsgemäß zurückzugeben ja wir
wollen Sie denn jetzt wieder mit dem
umgehen wir beraten ihren Punkte ja
schon lange erledigt und er war
natürlich ein Drama erstmal unser
geschrieben worden von Unternehmen und
von Leuten die offensichtlich eher bei
Ratingagenturen ihren an ihren sonstige
Beschäftigung haben sie wurde begünstigt
insbesondere wurden begünstigt die
Trittbrettfahrer es war so dass
letztendlich durch die Übernahme von
Unicorn und anderen die gasumlage
vollkommen obsolet vollkommen
überflüssig ist und trotzdem halten sie
an ihr fest wir beraten hier einen
Gegenstand der vollkommen erledigt ist
und das sage ich warum muss man das
eigentlich machen keine Sorgen weil sie
ihre Arbeit nicht ordentlich gemacht
haben die gasumlage war eine Katastrophe
und das merken wir bis heute
und wir haben in München lass diesen
Unfug nein sie haben den durchgezogen
bis heute mein Gott die Zeit sie rinnt
deshalb muss ich natürlich nochmal zum
anderen Punkt kommen und der ist wenn
das jetzt erledigt ist es gut dann haben
wir sie los aber das zweite was jetzt
machen 200 Milliarden auch richtig auch
was sie machen mit der mit den
Begrenzungen der Energiepreise ist ja
alles okay aber wie wollen Sie denn das
eigentlich machen und glauben Sie
tatsächlich dass 200 Milliarden in bis
2024 ausreichen da sage ich Ihnen Sie
werden nicht ausreichen die 200
Milliarden und sie werden und sie werden
dazu führen dass insbesondere kleinere
Einkommensbezieher
besonders belastet werden weil die in
der Regel an höheren Anteil ihres
Einkommens für Energie ausgeben und
nicht in der Lage sind die ganzen
Maßnahmen zu treffen die zum
Energiesparen notwendig sind das ist das
Problem und deshalb sage ich ihnen was
sie da machen das ist sozusagen ein
Schritt in die richtige Richtung das
beste war dass man diese gasumlage
beerdigt haben das Glöckchen hat man
schon länger Leuten hören nur sie nicht
ich danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
Klaus Ernst hat hier noch einmal begrüßt
dass die gasumlage jetzt erst einmal vom
Tisch ist
dazu direkt äußern kann sich nun Ingrid
Nestle von Bündnis 90 Dingen grünen
Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und Energie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Kollege Ernst langsam wird die Debatte
etwas kurios sie sagen wenn das so ist
dass Bayern genug Windstrom hat dann ist
ja alles gut
wenn das so ist ich als Norddeutsche
energiepolitikerin habe bisher dafür
gekämpft dass in ganz Deutschland
Industrie bezahlbare Strompreise
vorfindet das sind ganz Deutschland die
Windenergie ausgebaut wird
ich werde auch weiterhin dafür kämpfen
dass in ganz Deutschland die Windenergie
ausgebaut wird aber Herr Dobrindt wenn
Sie meinen dass das reicht was sie in
Bayern heute an bezahlbarer
Stromversorgung haben so kann ich nur
die herzliche Einladung an die Industrie
aussprechen bei uns im Norden gibt es
deutlich mehr davon
also wie gesagt wenn es nicht meine
Position ne ich finde bei ihnen sollte
es auch geben sie meinten dass er
ausreichend der zweite Punkt den ich
ansprechen möchte weil es jetzt zum
zweimal wieder durchkam man Bräuche
irgendeine Grundlast ja dieser Begriff
ist nun wirklich tiefste Vergangenheit
der Energieversorgung was man braucht zu
Ergänzung der wetterabhängigen und
kostengünstigen Erneuerbaren das ist
eben nicht Grundlast die ist nur im Weg
das ist eben Flexibilität
und die unter uns die unter uns die so
ein bisschen mitbekommen was in
Wissenschaft und Forschung abgeht die
wissen dass es längst erneuerbare Gase
gibt das ist natürlich ein neuerbare
Flexibilität gibt auf die wir setzen
und dann möchte ich gerne noch bei einem
weiteren Punkt von ihnen einen Haken
Herr Dobrindt sie sagten ganz zurecht
wir sind einem energiekrieg und wir
brauchen eine Kraftanstrengung das teile
ich
sie meinten dann aber erst wir bräuchten
sie nicht erst seit gestern da frage ich
Sie wo waren Sie denn bis gestern haben
sie nicht mitbekommen dass seit diese
Regierung die Verantwortung übernimmt
eine gigantische Krafteinstellung auf
den Weg gebracht ist haben sie nichts
mehr Ermer Markt von Gasspeicher gesetzt
energy-gesetz ersatzkraftwerke
bereitschaftsgesetz
energiesicherungsgesetz EEG
netzausbaugesetz haben sie nicht gemerkt
wie wir Gazprom Germania und rosnew
Putins Krallen Interessen haben wie
uniper verstaatlicht worden ist haben
Sie all das nicht mitbekommen
gefunden was sie jetzt mitbekommen ist
dass wir neben vielen entlastungspaketen
weil wir die Menschen und diesem Land
und die Unternehmen in diesem Land
unterstützen wollen und müssen dass wir
ein weitere 200 Milliarden in die Hand
nehmen müssen und diese 200 Milliarden
Herr Dobrindt diese 200 Milliarden das
sind ihre Rechnung das ist die Rechnung
für die Abhängigkeit von den fossilen
Energien von Putin und diese Rechnung
die müssen wir jetzt bezahlen und
gleichzeitig tun wir alles dafür Kollege
gleichzeitig ich habe die Uhr angehalten
gestanden sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
der Abgeordneten von Storch
nein doch
Beatrix von Storch aus der afd-fraktion
hat eine Zwischenfrage
ja vielen herzlichen Dank dass Sie
entgegen der Warnungen aus ihrer eigenen
Fraktion die Frage zulassen ich finde
das hat Größe wenn sie jetzt meine Frage
noch beantworten dann finde ich das noch
größer sie haben gerade davon von
Grundlast gesprochen die wir ja so
irgendwie nicht brauchen sie haben in
der letzten Aktuellen Stunde zum Thema
Blackout etwas ähnliches gesagt sie
haben gesagt wir brauchen wir haben eine
Energiekrise und sie haben gesagt der
Grund der Energiekrise ist dass die
französischen
Atomkraftwerke so schlecht liefern und
ich frage sie anerkennen Sie also dass
den Strom den wir brauchen die Grundlast
die wir brauchen doch wohl jetzt aus
Atomkraftwerken kommen muss und das ist
deswegen ein strategischer Fehler
gewesen ist insbesondere ihrer Partei
die Atomkraft in Deutschland abzustellen
also die modernsten sichersten
Kernkraftwerke der Welt abzustellen um
jetzt auf die französischen
Kernkraftwerke zu schimpfen dass die alt
und marode jetzt nicht mehr so viel
liefern wie wir jetzt brauchen weil wir
aus den modernen ausgestiegen sind ja
vielen Dank Frau von Storch dass ich das
noch mal ausführen darf also das Problem
an dem französischen Kraftwerken ist
dass wir Strom Menge brauchen und dass
diese sturmmenge jetzt nicht
bereitstellt bei der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien nicht
stattgefunden hat über die letzten Jahre
das Problem ist nicht dass wir Atomstrom
bräuchten das Problem ist dass wir
überhaupt Strom brauchen und das in der
Vergangenheit diese Ausbau nicht
stattgefunden hat weil man dachte die
Franzosen könnten sich mit ihrer
Atomenergie selbst versorgen was sie
nicht können was man jetzt sieht weil
sie plötzlich Strom von uns brauchen das
ist ja das Gegenteil von dem was eben
behauptet wurde wir würden auf den
Atomstrom von Frankreich schielen nein
wir müssen Frankreich unterstützen weil
die aktuellen Energie nicht läuft für
eine sichere Stromversorgung braucht man
selbstverständlich keine Grundlast eine
sichere Stromversorgung funktioniert so
dass der große Teil
mit viel bezahlbarerem Strom als es Atom
oder irgendeine fossile Quelle
bereitstellen kann der große Teil aus
Wind und Sonne kommt und ja das ist
besser abhängig deswegen muss man den
Rest des Stromsystems darauf einstellen
da können zum einen flexible Verbraucher
flexibel reagieren da haben auch alle
unflexiblen etwas davon wenn die
flexiblen Verbraucher in die Zeiten
gehen in denen viel da ist da kann man
interring über die Region hinweg sich
austauschen und gegenseitig unterstützen
aber etwas was Ihnen vielleicht eher
fremd ist und ja dann bleiben diese zwei
Wochen im Jahr wo es trotzdem schwierig
ist selbstverständlich etwas was wir
seit Jahren anerkennen und wo sie nie
anhören etwas was wir Ihnen seit Jahren
erklären wo sie immer wieder mit der
gleichen Frage kommen und behaupten wir
hätten diese Frage nicht beantwortet
seit Jahren haben wir sie beantwortet in
diesen zwei Wochen im Jahr kann die
Energieversorgung selbstverständlich
über Gaskraftwerke sichergestellt werden
mit Erneuerbaren Garten wir brauchen
keine fossile Flexibilität wir haben
neben dem flexibilitäten Speicher dem
Mahlzeit Mensch mit Austausch haben wir
die Möglichkeit
in den letzten paar Tagen im Jahr wo wir
das nicht hinbekommen
[Musik]
ich versuche tatsächlich gerade eben zu
erklären
in diesen letzten paar Tagen im Jahr für
diese Tage ist es kein Problem
erneuerbare Gase zu erzeugen natürlich
sind sie knapp ja natürlich ist
Wasserstoff
energieintensiv zu produzieren aber für
die Versorgungssicherheit da braucht man
nur wenig Wasserstoff und den können wir
bereitstellen wenn wir endlich auf die
Energiewende setzen wenn Sie nicht
ständig die Energiewende ausbremsen
würden dann hätten wir schon heute viel
mehr von diesem grünen Garten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen jetzt ist
meine Zeit fast abgelaufen deswegen
bleibt nur noch mal zu sagen dass wir
auch heute mit diesem
energiesicherungsgesetz wieder alles tun
was in unserer Macht steht um die
Knappheit des Gases zu reduzieren um
mehr Erneuerbaren noch für diesen Winter
bereits zu stellen um mehr Strom noch in
diesen Winter die Stromleitung zu
bekommen ja und auch so sehr ist mir weh
tut mehr Kohlestrom noch für diesen
Winter wir alle können zusammen heben
die Preise sind zu hoch weil Gas so
knapp ist wir alle können Putin die
Stirn bieten indem wir weniger davon
verbrauchen herzlichen Dank
ein Gerät in Nestlé war das hier doch im
sehr deutlichen Austausch mit den
anderen Abgeordneten während ihrer Rede
nun spricht Jens Spahn mittlerweile
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie gehen auch mit dem jetzt
vorgelegten Gesetzentwurf an was wir
seit Monaten immer wieder hier
vorgebracht haben insofern Herr Kollege
Kruse scheinen unsere Beiträge so gut zu
sein dass sie sie jetzt sogar umsetzen
das ist erstmal gut
das ist erstmal gut das unterstützen wir
auch aber leider und das muss man eben
auch hinzufügen einmal mehr tun sie es
zu spät und zu halbherzig und ich will
das auch ich will das auch kurz gerne
erläutern es ist richtig was sie jetzt
in diesem Gesetzentwurf machen deswegen
werden wir zustimmen bei Wind
ist doch wenn es vernünftig ist machen
wir auch mit bei Wind Biogas
Photovoltaik mehr Potenziale zu nutzen
übrigens ist ginge noch mehr wie wir in
unserem Entschließungsantrag deutlich
machen aber es ist eben nur ein Teil der
Befund ist ja jenseits aller auch
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen wir brauchen
erstmal mehr Angebot jede Kilowattstunde
zählt sagte der Minister richtigerweise
und wissen Sie was ich mir da wünschen
würde ich würde mir mal einen dreifach
Wumms wünschen erneuerbare ausbauen
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz und die
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen lassen das
wäre mal eine Maßnahme die in dieser
Krise ein Unterschied macht und den wir
hier seit März seit März vorschlagen und
vorbringen
zweitens die gasumlage weg haben sie
jetzt gemacht oder machen sie muss man
ja sagen noch ist sie übrigens in Kraft
die gasumlage Weg fordern wir seit
Monaten wir hatten hier letzte Woche ein
wie ich finde denkwürdigen Auftritt des
Ministers dazu aber vor allem haben wir
drei Monate Chaos Verwirrung
durcheinander gesehen Herr Kollege Kruse
nur um das nochmal zu sagen
Herr Kollege Kruse sie haben am Mittwoch
vor zwei Tagen im Ausschuss noch für
diese Umlage gestimmt jetzt soll sie bis
heute 13 Uhr im Umlaufbeschluss
abgeschafft werden wenn man sich so
schnell in so kurzer Zeit korrigieren
muss etwas weniger oberlehrerhafte
Belehrung und etwas mehr Demut wäre
vielleicht an dieser Stelle angebracht
immerhin die gasumlage kommt jetzt weg
was wir seit drei Monaten fordern auch
das unterstützen wir in der Sache es ist
richtig
gasgrundbedarf soll jetzt kommen
schlagen wir auch seit März vor und
nicht nur wir letzte Woche haben sie bei
der gasumlage gesagt sie bleibt und beim
gasgrundbedarf haben sie gesagt kommt
nicht beides passiert jetzt genau
andersrum wie sie es letzte Woche gesagt
haben es ist gut dass sie erkennen dass
sie da falsch schlagen aber ich finde
dann muss man ja etwas anders auftreten
und sich einlassen worum es geht beim
gasgrundbedarf und bei dem was sie
hoffentlich jetzt entwickeln ist doch
dass wir Sicherheit gehen morgen beginnt
offiziell die Heizperiode in Deutschland
die meisten haben wahrscheinlich die
Heizung angesichts der Temperaturen
schon hochgedreht und die Menschen gehen
jetzt in diesen Winter hinein die
Betriebe die Handwerk Unternehmen und
wissen eben nicht was auf sie zukommt
beim Gaspreis bei den Energiepreisen und
deswegen wäre eben dieser gasgrundbedarf
so wichtig dass es jetzt schnell geht
wenn es schnell geht und es vernünftig
ist werden wir auch das unterstützen
denn Liebe Kolle mit den Kollegen es ist
einfach viel Vertrauen verloren gegangen
in den letzten Monaten durch
Unsicherheit die verstärkt worden ist
sozialer Unfriede und das erleben wir ja
alle in den Diskussionen vor Ort der
entsteht nun also heißt es doppelwumms
und Olaf Scholz ist ja irgendwie der
Kanzler der markigen Worte Bazooka
zeitenwände doppelwumms nur leider
Folgen zu oft zu wenig Taten man muss
die Flughöhe dieser Worte dann auch
halten und deswegen kommt es jetzt auf
die Umsetzung an auch in den hoffentlich
nächsten Tagen und nicht Wochen denn das
was sie planen das ist wenn man jetzt
schaut auf das was vor uns liegt ihre
letzte Patrone
es ist die letzte Chance in unserem Land
in stressiger Zeit Vertrauen Sicherheit
Perspektive zu geben sie haben sich um
im Bild zu bleiben jetzt die Munition
zurechtgelegt 200 Milliarden Euro heißt
es sollen genutzt werden ob sie treffen
mit dem was sie tun bleibt nach den
Erfahrungen der letzten Monate noch
abzuwarten es bleibt dabei unser Angebot
und Sie sehen es heute morgen einmal
mehr dass wir sagen wenn das richtige
vorgelegt wird sind wir auch dabei und
stimmen zu es bleibt dabei unser Angebot
zu Zusammenarbeit und vor allem zum
gemeinsamen Erarbeiten von Lösungen
steht
machen dann auch gerne mit wenn Sie
sagen nein auch okay sie haben die
Mehrheit aber nach den rohrkrippieren
der letzten Monate wäre es gut wenn
diese letzte Schuss jetzt auch sitzt und
wenn Sie einmal in Schwarze treffen
dieses Land braucht dringend Sicherheit
Verlässlichkeit in stressiger in
krisenhaft der Zeit es ist was
angekündigt worden es ist einmal mehr
Salamitaktik ich verstehe das sowieso
nicht warum man gestern so eine
Pressekonferenz machen kann die Summe in
Schaufenster stellt und danach Vorhang
zu alle Fragen offen wir geben Ihnen
jetzt noch ein Stückchen Vorschuss an
dieser Stelle dass sie jetzt was
vernünftiges daraus machen aber machen
Sie es schnell und machen sie es diesmal
bitte richtig das Land braucht es
dringend
die Förderungen von Jens Spahn hier in
der Debatte zur
gaspreisanpassungsverordnung und
natürlich zu den Gaspreisen insgesamt
Vorletzter Redner ist Markus hümpfer
SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
die Lage ist dramatisch Herr Spahn das
haben wir glaube ich alle verstanden und
das brauchen wir auch nicht zu
beschönigen und ich kann Ihnen
versichern wir werden alles in unserer
Macht stehende tun um das was wir
angekündigt haben jetzt auch schnell
umzusetzen
die Anschläge auf nordstream 1 und 2
zeigen wie verwundbar unsere
Infrastruktur ist unsere Wirtschaft
unsere Gesellschaft die Menschen in
unserem Land haben Angst
davor im Winter frieren zu müssen Angst
davor dass der Strom ausfällt Angst vor
Jobverlust und Armut und diese Angst die
schwingt in jedem Gespräch mit dass ich
zurzeit führe und ich kann Ihnen sagen
ich will nicht dass Deutschland ein Land
der Angst ist
nehmen wir zum Beispiel Kerstin die
alleinerziehende Mutter lebt in einem
schlecht gedämmten Altbau mitten in
Schweinfurt heizt ihre kleine
Zweizimmerwohnung mit Erdgas viel
einsparen kann sie nicht
viel mehr bezahlen für Strom und Gas
kann sie auch nicht
wenn Kerstin vom
[Musik]
energieeinsparenergiesicherungsgesetz
hört fragt sie sich vielleicht was nützt
mir das senkt das meine Heizkosten das
nützt mir doch gar nichts und ich will
ihnen sagen kerstin hat nicht ganz
unrecht die Maßnahmen in diesem Gesetz
allein reichen nicht aus und deswegen
haben wir für über 90 Milliarden Euro
Entlastungsmaßnahmen auf den Weg
gebracht und mit der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse sorgen wir jetzt dafür
dass Energie bezahlbar bleibt
das ist aber nur eine Seite denn auf der
anderen Seite müssen wir gleichzeitig
das Energieangebot erweitern und deshalb
zünden wir den Booster für die
erneuerbaren Energien
wir tun alles Mögliche um die Situation
zu entspannen und das Ruder
herumzureißen und genau deshalb haben
wir das energiesicherungsgesetz jetzt
noch einmal verbessert wir sorgen dafür
dass kurzfristig mehr Strom über unsere
stromautobahn transportiert werden kann
von dieser von dieser Maßnahme
profitiert auch Kerstin denn damit
können wir mehr Strom von
Norddeutschland nach Bayern
transportieren so verhindern wir so
verhindern wir Blackouts in den
Bundesländern die kaum eigene
erneuerbare Energien haben und die den
Bau von Stromtrassen die den Bau von
Stromtrassen seit Jahrzehnten verhindern
und wir nutzen wir nutzen heimische
Ressourcen um die Versorgungssicherheit
zu gewährleisten Ressourcen die
CO2-neutral sind und nachwachsen ich
spreche von Biogas meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren von nun an können
Biogasanlagen mehr produzieren bisher
standen dem langwierige
Genehmigungsverfahren entgegen damit ist
jetzt erstmal Schluss wir können uns in
der aktuellen Lage das nicht leisten
und deshalb ändern wir das Baugesetzbuch
und ermöglichen so die zusätzliche
Produktion und 17 Kollege hümpfer
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
des Abgeordneten Hilse
von 17 Terawattstunden Gas das
entspricht sieben Terawattstunden Strom
oder mit anderen Worten ausgedrückt dem
Stromverbrauch von zwei Millionen
Haushalten das schafft
Versorgungssicherheit in diesem Winter
meine Damen und Herren
wir machen Energie bezahlbar und weiten
das Angebot aus wir tun alles dafür die
Versorgungssicherheit in Deutschland zu
gewährleisten wir tun alles dafür dass
aus Angst wieder Zuversicht wird in
diesem Land vielen Dank
markus hümper war das jetzt gibt es hier
die eine Kurzintervention von Carsten
helse aus der afd-fraktion bei seiner
Zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen wurde
die Kurzintervention zulassen Herr
hümpfer sie haben gerade gesagt es gäbe
quasi einen einen Strom es wird Strom
viel quasi vom Norden in den Süden
transportiert
agorameter schauen Sie einfach mal dort
rein was dort passiert Null im Moment
0,9 Gigawatt wird durch Windstrom
onshore produziert und davon wird
vielleicht etwas in den Süden und
andersrum stehen bei uns
Braunkohlekraftwerke die gerade 23
Gigawatt liefern das heißt der Strom
sozusagen wird nicht von ihnen zur Seite
vom Norden von Windkraftanlagen von
vogelschrettern geliefert und in den
Süden geliefert sondern wir liefern
gerade dem nordenstrom ansonsten würden
wir euch die Lichter ausgehen
sie haben das Wort zur Erwiderung
hätten sie mal zugehört hätten sie
gemerkt dass ich gesagt habe wir
ermöglichen mit diesem Gesetz dass wir
zukünftig mehr Strom von dem vom Norden
in den Süden transportieren können das
liegt daran dass es Bundesländer hier
gibt die den Netzausbau seit Jahren
verschleppen
so das war eine kurze Antwort hier auf
die Kurzintervention aber auch das ist
ja natürlich erlaubt und damit kommen
wir zum letzten Redner in dieser Debatte
das ist bankt bergt aus der SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
der Anschlag auf nordstream ist ein
Anschlag auf unsere Umwelt diese 500
Millionen Kubikmeter Erdgas die da jetzt
ausgetreten sind sind so viel wie 29
Millionen Tonnen CO2 das ist mal eben
der Jahresausstoß von Dänemark das ist
furchtbar das muss verfolgt werden meine
Damen und Herren
eine positiven Aspekt hat das aber im
Gegensatz zu früher sind wir jetzt
vorbereitet wir sind abgenabelt und gut
gerüstet für den Winter wir haben
mindest Füllstände für und die
Gasspeicher sind voll wir bauen
lng-ports und sie werden im Winter
fertig wir Boostern Wind solar- und
Biogas und es wird richtig viel Leistung
ins System schieben und ja auch Kohle
und Gas werden gebraucht weil wir nicht
nur Verantwortung für uns haben sondern
auch solidarisch mit unseren
europäischen Nachbarn sind
die Ampel die Ampel führt dieses Land
durch diese Krise und niemand wird
zurückgelassen meine Damen und Herren
die sichere Versorgung und bezahlbare
Energien werden kommen zufallsgewinne
werden abgeschöpft und der Ausbau der
Infrastruktur wird beschleunigt wir
bauen Stromnetze und geben jetzt Gas wo
Deutschland die letzten Jahre gepennt
hat meine Damen und Herren in diesem
solidarischen Kraftakt liegen
unglaubliche Chancen für unser Land wir
holen aus dem bestehenden
Windenergieanlagen noch zwei
Terawattstunden raus weil wir den
Betriebsmodus ändern das ist so viel wie
ein halbes Atomkraftwerk allein durch
die Beschleunigung der Verfahren für die
Windkraft Ebene wie den Weg für 10
Gigawatt mehr Leistung die seit Jahren
in den Genehmigung festhängen der
beschleunigen damit ganz konkret die
Wertschöpfung hier in Deutschland wird
Produktion hier bei uns und das ist
leider bitter nötig denn bei Siemens
gameser werden schon wieder 300 Stellen
gestrichen und 2500 in ganz Europa wir
brauchen offshore Turbinen aus Cuxhaven
wir brauchen onstor-turbinen aus Rostock
und Rendsburg Wälzlager Steinfurt
Getriebe aus Friedrichshafen alle
Installateure Dienstleister und
zulieferant ja auch der Bäcker der den
hart arbeitenden Menschen die
maurermarmelade auf die Butter schmiert
die brauchen wir alle bitte verstehen
Sie dass diese n-signovelle ein riesiges
beschleunigungsprogramm ist für die
Wertschöpfung hier direkt vor Ort und
liebes Wirtschaftsministerium bitte
versteht dass wir nicht nur die fossilen
stützen müssen sondern endlich die
Zukunftsenergien wer Leben gerade das
zweite solardebakel in der Windindustrie
live direkt vor unseren Augen wir müssen
jetzt schnell vorgehen denn der Rest der
Welt schläft auch nicht die Amerikaner
legen mit massiven Subventionen vor und
China schert sich um gar nichts und
selbst unser Nachbarländer bauen massiv
aus und fördern was das Zeug hält trotz
der fossilen Förderung die wir gerade
mit dem doppelwunsch auch vornehmen
bleibt es richtig dass wir als Ampel
damit die Härten abfedern dass wir die
Preise Deckeln aber das wäre wegen wäre
es auch genau allzu richtig als Staat
endlich in die Erneuerbaren einzusteigen
wir haben für viele Milliarden gerade
ein Gasriesen übernommen und kaufen
fossile Rohstoffe weil wir sie leider
noch brauchen wir können aber nach dem
absichtlichen herunterwirtschaften der
letzten Jahre die Wind und
Solarindustrie nicht einfach ihrem
Schicksal überlassen für einen Bruchteil
der Kosten für Juniper könnten wir
10.000 100.000 Arbeitsplätze hier in
Deutschland retten denn wenn wir das
nicht tun dann sind die nicht weg die
sind nur woanders und wir fangen uns die
gleiche Abhängigkeit ein vor der wir
jetzt flüchten müssen vielen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes und andere
energiewirtschaftlicher Vorschriften der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
3743 den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen
der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
auf Drucksache
3497 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen und
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die afd-fraktion und die Fraktion DIE
LINKE wer enthält sich
niemand der Gesetzentwurf ist damit in
zweiter Beratung angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
Dankeschön wer stimmt dagegen
danke schön wer enthält sich
der Gesetzentwurf ist mit den Stimmen
der Koalitionsfraktionen und der
cdu/csu-fraktion gegen die Stimmen der
afd-fraktion und der Fraktion DIE LINKE
angenommen
weiterhin empfiehlt der Ausschuss und
der Buchstabe b seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
3743 eine Entschließung anzunehmen wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
Dankeschön wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich danke die
Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den Stimmen
deren Koalitionsfraktionen gegen die
Stimmen der
cdu/csu-fraktion und der afd-fraktion
bei Enthaltung der Fraktionen die Linke
angenommen
wir stimmen nun über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktionen der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
3747 ab in diesem Entschließungsantrag
fordert die Union dass die
Bundesregierung schneller und mehr
reagieren muss bei ihrem
energiepolitischen Krisenmanagement und
fordert da bestimmte Maßnahmen zum
Beispiel den Ausbau
der Photovoltaik voranzutreiben den
Bericht des Ausschusses für
klimaschergie gemäß Paragraph 92 der
Geschäftsort dieser Entschließungsantrag
wurde hier abgelehnt Bundesregierung auf
Drucksache
sowie zu der Verordnung der
Bundesregierung zur Änderung der
gaspreisanpassungsverordnung auf
Drucksache
3434 haben wir zur Kenntnis genommen